[Musik]
guten Morgen wir sind live mit ZDF heute
live Russland feiert heute den Sieg über
Nazi Deutschland im Zweiten Weltkrieg
das ist ein Tag den Präsident Putin
jedes Jahr groß feiert da gibt es dann
eine große Militärparade die jetzt in
wenigen Minuten beginnen soll die soll
Russlands militärische Stärke zeigen in
der Regel hält Putin dann auch eine Rede
an die Nation im Anschluss wir sehen die
Bilder vom Roten Platz in Moskau
normalerweise kommen auch internationale
Staatsgäste das wird dieses Jahr wohl
nicht so sein überhaupt erscheint diese
ganze Veranstaltung in einem anderen
Licht denn Russland führt seit Februar
ein Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und
deshalb wirken diese Bilder auf den
einen oder anderen möglicherweise heute
befremdlich bis verstörend man geht
davon aus dass Präsident Putin diesen
Tag nutzen wird um die weitere Richtung
in diesem Krieg vorzugeben
jetzt sehen wir gerade wie die
Militärparade beginnt
deshalb schaut die Welt auch heute ganz
besonders auf Moskau und deshalb sind
wir heute live wir sprechen gleich mit
unserem Korrespondenten Christian sem in
Moskau und mit unserer Korrespondentin
Katrin Eigendorf in Kiew und wir haben
auch eine Expertin Julia Friedrich vom
global
policy public policy Institute ihr könnt
uns eure Fragen schicken und eure
Kommentare die könnt ihr gerne an die
Adresse schicken die ihr jetzt
eingeblendet seht oder ihr schreibt sie
einfach in die Kommentarspalten wir
wollen so viel wie möglich davon
besprechen und beginnen jetzt mit Julia
Friedrich einen schönen guten Morgen
guten Morgen Frau Friedrich sie haben
selbst in Russland gelebt einige Zeit
lang sie haben bis kurz vor Kriegsbeginn
in Kiew gearbeitet kennen sich also sehr
gut aus in dieser Thematik schauen wir
vielleicht erstmal auf Russland das Land
feiert eben diesen Sieg über Nazi
Deutschland sie haben diese
Feierlichkeiten in Russland auch schon
erlebt wie wichtig ist den Russen und
Russen dieser Tag
danke also der 9 mai ist eigentlich mit
der wichtigste Feiertag in Russland das
ist ein Tag der häufig von der gesamten
Familie begangen wird in der Regel ist
es auch so dass zwischen dem ersten und
dem 9 mai das sind zwei Feiertage und
dazwischen das wie so eine Art
Feiertagsstimmung auch in Russland aber
der 9 mai ist auf jeden Fall ein auch
ein ideologischer und ein patriotischer
Feiertag und wird so auch von den
Russinnen wahrgenommen also es gibt ja
manchmal auch Feiertage bei denen weiß
man gar nicht unbedingt jeder so genau
worum es geht und bei 9 mai ist das
nicht der Fall dass es ganz klar eben
der Tag des Sieges der sich auch über
die Jahre gewandelt hat und mittlerweile
ist es eben ein Tag sozusagen für das
für das ganze Volk alle sind auf den
Straßen und eben zum Großteil auch bei
diesen bei diesen Paraden
sie haben es gerade gesagt das Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges wird ja meist mit
dem Gedenken an die Opfer verknüpft
Putin feiert den Triumph den stellt er
den Vordergrund was sagt das aus
ja also das war gar nicht immer so zur
Zeit in der Sowjetunion die ersten
ungefähr 20 Jahre wurde dieser 9 mai gar
nicht so begangen und das hat sich dann
unter Breschnew ab 1965 ungefähr hat
sich das dann gewandelt und das denn der
der Sieg über Nazi Deutschland der Sieg
über den Faschismus ist das
sinnstiftende Element insbesondere unter
Putins Herrschaft dort hat
ironischerweise dann ja schon viele
viele Jahrzehnte nach dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges hat dieser Feiertag
eben diese ideologische Bedeutung
gewonnen wir stehen auf der Seite des
Guten wir haben das Böse besiegt mit ja
unglaublich hohen Verlusten aber unter
Putin war eben dann die zunehmende
Loslösung von der gelebten Erfahrung der
Menschen die veteran:innen sterben mehr
mittlerweile auch aus muss man sagen
also es gibt ja nur noch sehr wenige
Menschen die tatsächlich als Soldatinnen
in diesem Krieg gekämpft haben und somit
hat sich das Gedenken losgelöst von der
eigentlichen gesellschaftlichen Tragödie
die dieser Krieg dargestellt hat und ist
jetzt eben auch eine eine Schaustellung
der russischen macht geworden und der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine der aktuelle
Krieg wird ja von Präsident Putin der
russischen Bevölkerung als eine Art
Fortsetzung des Kriegs gegen die Nazis
verkauft nehmen die Menschen ihm dieses
narrativ ab
das ist eine gute Frage also es ist ganz
zentral dass es eben dass das die
Ukraine als faschistisch als dass die
Ukraine innen als Nazis bezeichnet
werden das ist ganz zentral zum zum
russischen narrativ dieses Krieges
inwiefern die Bevölkerung das glaubt
also oberflächlich hat das auf jeden
Fall gegriffen ich meine es ist ja auch
schon seit acht Jahren so dass der
Bevölkerung eben dieses narrativ
gefüttert wird von den Ukrainerinnen als
Faschisten als Nazis aber wie nachhaltig
dieser Glaube dann tatsächlich ist das
plötzlich glaube ich erst über die Zeit
herausstellen ob man das wirklich
ob man das wirklich verinnerlicht hat
oder ob das mehr mehr so einen
vordergründiges akzeptieren dieses
Narrativs jetzt ist das aber nicht
unbedingt zu einer über zu Überzeugung
führt dass es momentan noch ein bisschen
schwer jetzt zu sagen
vielen Dank Frau Friedrich für den
Moment wir sprechen gleich noch weiter
sie bleiben noch bei uns netterweise
an das Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs ist
in Europa auch gestern in Deutschland
erinnert worden auf völlig andere Art
und Weise Henriette de Maiziere
berichtet
sie waren die Sieger und wurden die
Befreier die sowjetische Armee am 8 mai
1945 vor 77 Jahren endet in Europa der
Zweite Weltkrieg nun gibt es wieder
Krieg in Europa und so wendet sich
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz mit einer
Fernsehansprache an die Menschen darin
betont er es sei geschichtsverfälschend
und in Farm wie Putin den Angriffskrieg
mit dem Kampf gegen den
Nationalsozialismus gleichsetze in der
gegenwärtigen Lage kann dies nur
bedeuten wir verteidigen Recht und
Freiheit an der Seite der angegriffenen
wir unterstützen die Ukraine im Kampf
gegen den orgressor
das nicht zu tun hier ist sie zu
kapitulieren vor blanker Gewalt und den
Aggressor zu bestärken dieser 8 Mai sei
wie kein anderer es gehe buchstäblich
und Krieg und Frieden
aus vielen Äußerungen die ich dieser
Tage höre spricht ernste Sorge Sorge
auch davor dass sich der Krieg ausweitet
dass der Frieden auch bei uns in Gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche Sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt Angst darf uns nicht
lehnen auf dem Bundeskongress des
Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbundes in Berlin
sagt Bundespräsident Frank-Walter
Steinmeier heute dieser Krieg sei ein
Bruch mit vielem was uns als
Selbstverständlichkeit es sei ein
Epochenbruch
es sind
Gewalt vor denen wir stehen absehbar
noch sehr viel tiefer und tiefgreifender
als wir sie heute diskutieren auch
deshalb spreche ich von einem
Epochenbruch die Debatte über den
systemkonflikt zwischen Demokratien und
autoritären Regimen über die Zukunft der
Globalisierung und unsere Verantwortung
in der Welt
diese Debatte steht mit höchster
Dringlichkeit auf der Tagesordnung
unsere Demokratie müsse beschützt werden
nach innen und außen das zeige auf
brutale Weise dieser Krieg so Steinmeier
und spricht von Barbarei in diesem 8 mai
ist der Traum des gemeinsamen
europäischen Hauses gescheitert
ein Albtraum ist an seine Stelle
getreten diese 8 Mai sein Tag des
Krieges die Bilder des zerstörten Berlin
1945 sie ähneln den aktuellen Bildern
aus der Ukraine
und wir schalten jetzt live nach Kiew zu
Kathrin Eigendorf hallo Katrin
hallo guten Morgen guten Morgen Katrin
wie besorgt blicken die Menschen in der
Ukraine jetzt auf diese bevorstehende
Rede von Präsident Putin
einmal hat die ukrainische Regierung
ganz konkret davor gewarnt dass die
Angriffe sicherlich zunehmen werden dass
man wirklich aufpassen muss dass es hier
verstärkt auch zu Angriffen wieder auf
Kiew kommen kann aber auf eigentlich
jede Stadt in der Ukraine das ist das
was die Menschen hier ganz konkret
besorgt aber abgesehen davon besorgt
natürlich die gesamte Ukraine das Putin
diesen Tag nutzen wird den 9 mai um noch
einmal ganz deutlich in diesem Krieg zu
eskalieren also das irgendeine
Ankündigung von Putin kommt die der
Ukraine noch weiteren Schaden zufügt die
möglicherweise auf eine deutliche
Eskalation auch der Kampfhandlungen
hinausläuft bis hin zu der Spekulation
das Putin an diesem Tag ankündigen
könnte den Osten der Ukraine also ganz
konkret die Republiken luchansk und Don
jetzt in die Russische Föderation durch
eine Referendum einzugliedern also man
wartet hier eigentlich mit
ängstlicher Spannung darauf was heute
aus Moskau zu hören sein wird von
Wladimir Putin
die Rede ist von einer teil- oder
general mobilenmachungen was ja insofern
seltsam anmutet als das Präsident Putin
die ganze Zeit von einer
spezialoperation geredet hat dann müsste
er ja seinem Volk sagen dass es jetzt
ein Krieg
ja das halte ich auch für entsprechend
problematisch weil dieser Krieg in der
Ukraine und auch der 9 mai den die
Russen heute begehen hat eine gewisse
Popularität und Unterstützung bei auch
einigen Kreisen der Bevölkerung es ist
schwer das zu beziffern aber es ist
nicht so dass dieser Krieg auf
kompletten Widerstand in Russland stößt
aber wenn es natürlich konkret an das
eigene Leben geht das heißt wenn Mütter
ihre Söhne jetzt in diesen Krieg
schicken müssen wenn Russland hier ganz
konkret weitere Opfer bringen muss dann
kann ich mir vorstellen riskiert Putin
auch den Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung zu
verlieren denn das haben wir auch bei
anderen Kriegen vorher schon erlebt also
ich nenne mal als Beispiel den Krieg in
Tschetschenien der ist ja im Prinzip hat
sich ja ganz dramatisch gegen Russland
entwickelt weil immer mehr Soldaten
Mütter hinterher hingegangen sind und
haben gesagt wir wollen nicht unsere
Söhne in diesem Krieg
Opfern deswegen könnte ich mir das
problematisch vorstellen auf der anderen
Seite mit Putin natürlich auch unter
Druck es sieht so aus militärisch kann
er diesen Konflikt im Moment nicht
wirklich für sich gewinnen also es gibt
nicht den angedachten schnellen Sieg den
er hier erzielen wollte ganz im
Gegenteil die russische Armee zeigt
eigentlich hier ihren komplett desolaten
Zustand Missmanagement falsche
Ausrüstung Korruption
Soldaten die eigentlich weder wissen
wofür sie kämpfen noch überhaupt
wirklich kampfbereit sind deswegen
könnte dieser Punkt general Mobilmachung
durchaus eine Option sein auch gegen
sicherlich den Willen vor allem der
jungen Bevölkerung aber das ist im
Moment alles Spekulationen es ist
wirklich sehr schwierig sich im Moment
ein Bild über das zu machen was in
diesem inneren Kreis rund um Putin
wirklich gedacht und gemacht wird weil
im Prinzip hat die Regierung in Russland
einen eisernen informationsvorhang um
sich herum gezogen und
tierisch öffentlichen Stellungnahmen
kann man ja auch nicht mehr wirklich
ernst nehmen haben sich ja eigentlich in
den ja seit Anfang des Jahres und auch
davor schon als ein Sammelsurium von
Desinformationen Propaganda und Lügen
erwiesen deswegen können wir einfach nur
abwarten und ich erwarte persönlich auch
mit großer Spannung was Wladimir Putin
seiner Bevölkerung heute sagen wird aber
es wird natürlich auch ein Signal an die
Welt sein weil es geht natürlich
Russland auch darum welche Stellung das
Land in der Welt spielt und welches
narrativ dieser neunte mai welches
narrativ sich hier durchsetzt und was ja
interessant ist
es wurde ja gerade schon angesprochen es
war ja nicht immer so dass dieser neunte
mai als heldentag als siegestag in
dieser Form gefeiert wurde sondern man
hat ja durchaus auch zu Beginn der
Amtszeit von Wladimir Putin mit
westlichen Staatschefs gemeinsam diesen
Tag begangen übrigens auch mit deutschen
Staatschefs die in Moskau eingeladen
wurden und mit Putin dort
zusammenstanden also im Prinzip diese
Veränderung des Narrativs was wir jetzt
erleben geht einher mit der deutlichen
Distanzierung Russlands das immer mehr
Position gegen den Westen bezieht und
während du sprichst sehen wir die Bilder
dieser Militärparade und sehen jetzt
auch gerade Präsident Putin der gleich
seine Rede halten wird wir schauen kurz
in den Chat Chrissi schreibt ich habe
große Angst dass der Putin heute was
macht mit was keiner gerechnet hat Ronny
schreibt mich erinnert diese Parade an
1938 im Deutschen Reich mit den Nazis
schrecklich wir geben jetzt mal das
große Bild drauf und warten ab ob
Präsident Putin jetzt gleich sprechen
wird
[Musik]
sehr geehrter Bürger und Bürgerinnen
Föderation Liebe Veteranen
Soldaten und Matrosen
Unteroffiziere und Mate fendriche und
Offiziere
generale und Admirale
ich beglückwünsche Sie zum Tag des
großen Sieges
da Schutz unserer Heimat damals und
heute ist heilig mit diesem Gefühl vom
wahren Patriotismus erhoben sich
die Leute um Minen und paarschatzki wir
haben die Schlacht auf Borodino erlebt
und schlechter vom Moskau Längengrad
Stalingrad
genau solche Gefühle haben wir
heutzutage genauso kämpfen sie
heutzutage für
für die Sicherheit unserer Heimat
Russlands der 9 mai 1945
ist ein Tag der für immer in die
Weltgeschichte eingegangen ist als
Triumph unseres einigen sowjetischen
Volkes
das ist ein Beispiel für Heldentaten an
der Front und im Hinterland der Tag des
Sieges ist nah und heilig für alle von
uns in Russland gibt es kaum eine
Familie die vom Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht
getroffen wäre diese Erinnerung wird
wach gehalten
heute wird es eine Veranstaltung vom
unsterblichen Regiment geben die
Verwandten werden die Fotos zeigen von
ihren Verwandten von gefallenen Soldaten
die für immer jung geblieben sind und
auch von Veteranen die schon von uns
gegangen sind wir sind
auf diese ruhmreiche Generation der
Sieger und wer sind stolz darauf dass
wir Ihre Erde sind
unsere Schuld ist es die Erinnerung kann
sich wachzug halten an diejenigen die
den Nationalsozialismus besiegt haben
und uns gesagt haben dass der Krieg sich
nicht wiederholen soll deswegen obwohl
es natürlich auch verschiedene Meinungen
dann internationalen Beziehungen gibt
hat Russland Thema dafür aufgetreten
einen Sicherheitssystem aufzustellen und
das ist nötig für die gesamte
Weltgemeinschaft im Dezember letzten
Jahres haben wir vorgeschlagen einen
Vertrag über die Sicherheitsgarantien
abzuschließen wir haben dazu aufgerufen
dass wir eine dialoglösung finden und
einander hören aber alles war umsonst
die NATO-Länder wollten uns nicht hören
heißt dass sie in Wirklichkeit ganz
andere Pläne hatten und wir sehen das
haben sie eine weiter
vorbereitet sie haben beabsichtigt auf
unserer Territorium inklusive Creme
einzudringen in Kiew hat man offen davon
gesprochen dass man noch klarwaffen
einsetzen kann und die Nato hat sich auf
territorinnen weiter die historisch für
uns gehörten das heißt das war eine ganz
offensichtliche Bedrohung für uns
unmittelbar vor unseren Grenzen alles
sprach davon dass eine mögliche
Konfrontation mit der Neonazis in den
bandera Anhängern die von den USA und
ihren unterstützt werden
entwickelt wurde
ausländische
kriegsberater waren im Land tätig diese
Bedrohung wuchs mit jedem Tag das heißt
russland hat ein präventiven das war
die einz
eine Lösung eines starken souveränen
Landes
hat die USA davon gesprochen dass sie
einzigartig sind sie haben die ganze
Welt und ihre Satelliten müssen alles
hinnehmen alles runterschlucken aber wir
sind ein anderes Land russland hat einen
anderen Charakter wir werden nie darauf
setze ich in unsere Heimat zu lieben wir
halten fest an unseren Glauben an die
Tradition und zwar Vorfahren wir
respektieren alle Völker und Kulturen
wir haben tausendjährige traditionswerte
Absagen das heißt die Geschichte des
Zweiten Weltkrieges oder verdreht
tropophobie
Verräter
die Erinnerung
die amerikanischen Veteranen die diese
Siegesparade heute besuchen wollten
wo das verboten aber ich will dass er
wissen wir sind stolz auf sie
sind stolz auf ihren Beitrag zum
gemeinsamen Sieg und es geht auch um die
britischen Soldaten und der
amerikanischen französischen Soldaten
Partisanen alle die gegen den
Nationalsozialismus und Militarismus
gekämpft haben
in der Armee von Russland kämpfen heute
auf dem eigenen Land genauso
die Soldaten von romance vom heiligen
Ladina gekämpft haben da auf diesem Land
gab es Kämpfe im Großen Vaterländischen
Krieg
ich möchte mich nur an unsere Streit
unterrichten
sie kämpfen für die Heimat für die
Zukunft dafür dass niemand die Lehren
des Zweiten Weltkrieges vergisst damit
es keine Teilnehmer auf der Welt gibt
keine Nazis heute verneigen wir uns tief
vor dem Gedenken an diejenigen die im
Zweiten Weltkrieg gefallen sind
alle Väter Töchter Söhne
Großväter
Ehefrau und Ehemänner Brüder und
Schwestern wurden
Opfern von Adessa die 2014 ihr Leben im
Gewerkschaftshaus verloren haben wir
verlangen uns die vor Frauen und alten
von
Zivilisten die
ums Leben gekommen sind
Soldaten die gefallen sind im Kampf für
Russland ich möchte nun eine
Schweigeminute anlegen
der Tod von jedem einzigen Soldaten oder
Offizier von uns ist ein großes Leid für
uns alle dass sein Verlust für ihre
Familie
unternehmen
der Staat fährt alles tun um solchen
Familien zu helfen und dann
Hinterbliebenen zu helfen es wird eine
besondere Unterstützung zugeteilt für
die Kinder von diesen gefallenen
Soldaten heute habe ich könnte man
sprechen
und ich wünsche eine rasche Genesung an
diejenigen Soldaten Offiziere die
verwundet waren mein Dank gilt allen
Ärzten Krankenschwestern Personal
internationen für ihre Arbeit ich
verneige mich tief vor ihnen danke dass
ihr für jedes Leben kämpfen oft unter
der Schuss an der Frontlinie
hier auf dem Roten Platz Schulte ein
Schulter stehen Soldat und Offiziere aus
vielen Regionen unserer Heimat unserer
großen Heimat auch diejenigen die direkt
aus dem dornbas angereist sind von der
Front
Russlands in Gruppen von internationalen
Terroristen gegen uns ein Gesetz haben
man hat versucht uns auch von ihnen zur
zerstören aber das hat nicht
funktioniert heute unsere Kämpfer unsere
Soldaten von verschiedenen
Herkunft kämpfen zusammen wie Brüder und
helfen sich gegenseitig das ist die
Kraft Russlands große Kraft unseres
einigen
internationalen heute kämpfen sie dafür
ach so ohne
Väter gekämpft haben für Sie das höhere
Ziel immer war
das Heimat und die Sicherheit unserer
Heimat wir sind ihre Erben und das ist
auch unser wert
Hauptsache ist die Unabhängigkeit
Russland
diejenigen die gegen den
Nationalsozialismus im Zweiten Weltkrieg
gekämpft haben haben uns ein Beispiel
von Heldentaten gegeben das ist eine
Generation der Sieger und sie werden uns
immer ein Beispiel sein warum unseren
[Musik]
ja das war die Rede von Präsident Putin
anlässlich des Sieges der
Russen über Nazi Deutschland im Zweiten
Weltkrieg ich fasse mal kurz zusammen ja
Putin hat weil dieser Militärparade in
Moskau den Einsatz der russischen
Streitkräfte in der Ukraine gewürdigt
die Soldaten würden im dornbas in der
Ostukraine für die Sicherheit Russlands
kämpfen sagte er und die Ukraine habe
sich aufgerüstet mit Waffen der NATO und
so eine Gefahr dargestellt für Russland
und deshalb müsse man sich verteidigen
Präsident putinat gesprochen danach
hörte man jetzt die russische Hymne und
Kanonenschüsse und wir schalten jetzt
nach Moskau auf den Roten Platz zu
unserem Korrespondenten Christian sem
hallo Christian hallo aus Moskau
natürlich auch verfolgt
ganz spontan dein erster Eindruck
[Musik]
mein Eindruck ist es ja eigentlich
bekanntes wiederholt hat er hat ja noch
mal gesagt dass Russland sich bedroht
fühle durch die NATO und die Aufrüstung
der Ukraine und auch das Argument das
die russophobie weiter um sich greift
das hören wir jetzt auch nicht zum
ersten Mal und wir haben gar nichts
gehört in Richtung mobil machen da war
die Sorge ja international groß aber
auch hier bei vielen Russinnen und
Russen dass er das verkünden könnte und
in die Richtung hat er gar nichts gesagt
in die Richtung was erwartet wurde von
wegen Teilsieg erklären Teil mobil
machen general mobil machen hat er ja
eigentlich wirklich gar nichts gesagt
was jetzt irgendwie die weitere Richtung
in diesem Krieg vorgeben könnte
eigentlich hat er sehr viel davon
gesprochen dass Russland sich
verteidigen muss und hat sein Land doch
eher in so einer Art
Opferrolle gesetzt
ja es hat auf jeden Fall mal wieder
gezeigt dass man tatsächlich vorher nie
weiß was passiert und was Wladimir Putin
sagen wird und was ich hinter den
kreml-mauern tatsächlich tut ich finde
er hat schon noch mal versucht deutlich
zu machen warum diese Militäroperation
wichtig ist und wenn er sozusagen vom
Erbe spricht der Veteran das heute
fortgeführt werden muss dann ist das
glaube ich eine Argumentation und eine
Erklärung auch an das russische Volk
warum das was gerade in der Ukraine
passiert warum das unbedingt sein muss
und was ist deine Einschätzung ist
dieses narrativ dass er da fortführt aus
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg ist das denn
wirklich glaubhaft für die Mehrheit der
Russinnen und Russen
[Musik]
ein bisschen laut hier ich hoffe ich
habe das richtig verstanden ich glaube
das wird recht unterschiedlich
aufgenommen manche folgen diesem
narrativ und Folge auch ihrem
Präsidenten und wir haben das die
letzten Tage auch immer wieder gesehen
diese patriotischen Symbole die immer
wieder gezeigt werden auch das Orange
schwarze siegesbändchen was immer wieder
gerne von den Menschen auch gezeigt wird
was mittlerweile auch zu einem Symbol
ist Symbol geworden ist um die Politik
von Wladimir Putin zu unterstützen also
ich glaube da gibt es doch einige die im
Folgen es gibt aber auch viele die
dagegen sind nur fehlt diesen Menschen
die Möglichkeit diesen Protest Protesten
irgendeiner Form auch auf die Straße zu
bringen dann zum Beispiel vor einigen
Tagen hier in der Nähe gedreht bei den
Proben zur Militärparade wo sich abends
hier schon die Panzer gesammelt haben
und wurden diese Parade geübt wurde da
waren einige zaung Gäste mit denen haben
wir gesprochen was ihr von dem Feiertag
erhalten dann sagen sie ja das ist
natürlich immer noch ein wichtiger
Feiertag für uns
gefragt was halten Sie denn aktuell von
der militärischen spezialoperationen
sowie das was in der Ukraine passiert
hier bezeichnet werden muss und da merkt
man dass die Menschen wirklich Angst
haben in die Kamera in das Mikrofon
offen zu antworten und wirklich zu sagen
was sie darüber denken weil sie doch
Sorge haben dass auch nur die leiseste
Kritik an dieser Militäroperation dass
ihnen das Probleme machen kann was die
Menschen dann wirklich denken dass
erfährt man dann eher wenn die Kamera
aus ist vielen Dank für deine
Schilderungen und deine Eindrücke vom
Roten Platz in Moskau danke Christian
bis bald tschüss
gerne tschüss und wir fragen noch mal
nach bei unserer Expertin Julia
Friedrich vom global public policy
Institute in Berlin Frau Friedrich auch
sie haben die Rede eben
begleitet wie würden Sie die Worte von
Putin einordnen entspricht das so dem
was Sie erwartet haben
also ich glaube es war vorher sehr
schwer es gab eine ganze Bandbreite an
Möglichkeiten dessen was er hätte sagen
können in verschiedenen schweren
Szenarien ich glaube im einfach nach
dessen was möglich gewesen wäre war es
mit der softe Szenario wie er auch
bereits gerade gesagt wurde hat er
vieles wiederholt was wir schon kennen
also diese Begründung durch die
Bedrohung durch NATO und die USA
der russische Präventivschlag gegen
diese Bedrohung gleichzeitig hat man
aber gemerkt dass er sich stark in Bezug
auf die Ukraine stark auf den Don Bass
konzentriert hat also
weiterhin diese Linie fährt das jetzt
eben die die das Ziel der der
sogenannten spezialoperation eben der
Donbass ist und nicht mehr die die
gesamte Ukraine
das kann man als als Zeichen werden dass
er zumindest jetzt den heutigen Tag
nicht dazu nutzt um die die Kriegsziele
nochmal zu erweitern und eben auch eine
Mobilmachung auszurufen die ja sehr
riskant für ihn gewesen wäre diesen
Schritt hat er offensichtlich nicht
machen wollen was ich schon fast
ironisch fand war dass dass er gesagt
hat wir werden uns kümmern um die
Hinterbliebenen der gefallenen Soldaten
wir werden uns um die die Verwundeten
kümmern weil ja bekanntermaßen die
russischen Soldaten ihre gefallenen
Kameraden
zu Hunderten eben in der Ukraine lassen
und nicht mit und nicht mit
zurückgenommen haben also ja dabei dass
das nur am Rande ich würde sagen also er
hat eindeutig dieses spezialoperation in
die Traditionen des Sieges überall Nazi
Deutschland gestellt er hat auch wieder
Sieges Gewissheit auch diesmal geäußert
aber im Rahmen dessen was möglich
gewesen wäre war es jetzt eher ein eines
der Soft darin Szenarien
wir haben gerade eine größere Diskussion
im Chat denn einige sind der Meinung
dass man die Rede von Präsident Putin
überhaupt nicht zeigen sollte dazu gibt
es Kommentare von Roger z.B auf Facebook
der sagt dies sollte nicht live gesendet
werden so würde man helfen Lügen zu
verbreiten denn es wird mal wieder
einige schlecht informierte Glauben
Bernhard schickt uns eine mail warum
bietet das ZDF dem Aggressor und
Tyrannen Putin noch eine solche Bühne
seine Machtdemonstration und das auch
noch live ja wir machen das um eben
diese Rede einzuordnen mit Experten mit
Korrespondentin und Korrespondenten
damit diese Rede eben nicht so stehen
bleibt mit den Worten die er gesprochen
hat sondern wir dieses narrativ erklären
können kritisieren können und eben auch
einordnen können was wir eben gerade mit
unserer Expertin Julia Friedrich machen
Frau dieses narrativ dass er die ganze
Zeit erzählt wo er die ganze Zeit sagt
dieses Erbe aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
diesen Kampf gegen die Nazis muss man
jetzt in der Ukraine weiterführen
vielleicht können sie noch mal ganz klar
sagen
wo ist da die Verdrehung der Geschichte
naja also es ist eine komplette
Verdrehung der Geschichte die Ukraine
hat eine demokratisch gewählte Regierung
die nicht auseinander ziehen sondern aus
demokratischen besteht die dass die
sozusagen rechten Parteien in der
Ukraine gekriegen ich glaube zwei
Prozent aber auch schon seit Jahrzehnten
in den Parlaments und Wahlen also das
ist eine eine demokratische legitime
Regierung die eine Politik macht die
Herrn Putin nicht gefällt und weil Herr
Putin gerne die Ukraine kontrollieren
möchte hat er sie überfallen und
versucht sie mit Gewalt zu seinem Willen
zu beugen und die die Ironie besteht
natürlich darin dass das viele Menschen
in der Ukraine die jetzt diesen Krieg
erleben dass der ganz viele Erinnerungen
weckt für den ukrainer:innen an den
diesen zweiten Weltkrieg erlebt haben
eben an diesen Krieg also es gab auch
Berichte zum Beispiel von älteren
Menschen die die die russischen Soldaten
die deutschen genannt haben weil es eben
genau diese Erinnerungen wieder weckt
und jetzt zu sagen dass man ja im
gleichen Zuge wie die wie die Befreiung
von den Nationalsozialisten jetzt eben
Zerstörung und Tod über die Ukraine
bringt dass es ja das ist wirklich eine
komplette komplette Drehung der
Wirklichkeit und das stellt ja auch also
das narrativ ist ja natürlich auch der
sowjetische Sieg über Nazi Deutschland
war quasi der russische Sieg und das das
stimmt natürlich auch nicht denn damals
war es eben die Rote Armee der
Sowjetunion zu der sehr viele Staaten
gehörten unter anderem auch die Ukraine
und Belarus
die die gemeinsam gegen Nazi Deutschland
gekämpft haben also das ist es ist
einfach an allen Ecken und Enden macht
es eigentlich keinen Sinn dieses
narrativ
und was denken sie wie wird dieser Tag
heute den weiteren Kriegsverlauf in der
Ukraine beeinflussen
also das kann ich natürlich nicht
voraussagen ich denke dass es keine
general Mobilmachung gab zumindest heute
nicht es erstmal vielleicht ein Zeichen
dass das wir jetzt erstmal eine
Kontinuität dessen sehen werden was
bereits passiert also weiterhin
schlimme Kämpfe im Soundbars
Raketenangriffe in der gesamten Ukraine
aber eben zumindest heute keine weitere
keine wiederholte Erweiterung der
Kriegsziele
und ja viel mehr glaube ich kann man am
heutigen Tag nicht sagen
und damit möchte ich mich bei Ihnen
bedanken vor Friedrich und wir haben
gerade im Chat gesehen wie wichtig es
eben ist dass ExpertInnen wie sie
verdrehte Wahrheiten richtig stellen und
eben auch immer immer wieder erklären
danke Frau Friedrich tschüss
sehr gerne und damit gehen wir jetzt
noch mal nach Kiew zu unserer Reporterin
Katrin Eigendorf Katrin dich möchte ich
natürlich fragen
wie diese Rede in der Ukraine
aufgenommen wurde gibt es da schon
Reaktionen
nein es gibt dazu noch keine Reaktionen
es ist aber so dass im Prinzip der
Auftritt Putins ja hier schon von
selenski vorweggenommen wurde in dem er
heute morgen ein Video veröffentlicht
hat wieder einmal ein Video
veröffentlicht hat muss man sagen indem
er erklärt was die Position der Ukraine
zur aktuellen Geschichte ist und er
dreht es eben genau um und er sagt die
Ukraine hat Nazideutschland bekämpft
zurückgeschlagen
und die Ukraine wird genauso wie sie es
damals geschafft hat Nazi Deutschland
zurückzuschlagen ist auch schaffen heute
die russische Armee hier zurück zu
schlagen und die Geschichtsverfälschung
die Putin betreibt im Prinzip damit
dieses narrativ konterkariert und
eigentlich ja das aus der Perspektive
der Ukraine geschildert was ja
interessant ist was wir hier sehen ist
dass wir es mit einer Neuschreibung der
Geschichte zu tun haben wir haben ja
alle geglaubt die Geschichte des Zweiten
Weltkriegs ist geschrieben aufgearbeitet
wir Deutschen haben sie aufgearbeitet
aber das ist sie eben nicht wir sehen
hier zwei Länder die einen völlig andere
Perspektive auf das Ende des Zweiten
Weltkrieges haben und das ist auch nicht
neu
russland hat sich immer als Sieger macht
definiert und diesen Tag begangen im
Prinzip als heldental das war in der
Ukraine auch vorher schon ein bisschen
anders man hat hier deutlich gesehen
dass auch der Stalinismus das die
Ukraine Opfer von zwei totalitären
Systemen geworden ist und war nämlich
das Stalinismus und Nazi Deutschlands
das ist eine ganz andere Perspektive auf
die Geschichte als wir sie in Russland
sehen und das kommt natürlich heute
an diesem neunten mai da Russland den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine führt noch mal
ganz besonders deutlich zum Tragen und
das ist glaube ich wichtig dass wir das
verstehen dass die Geschichte so wie wir
sie gesehen haben
eben nicht die Geschichte ist wie sie
sich für die Ukraine darstellt
Präsident Putin hat ja eben in seiner
Rede der NATO die Schuld an der
Eskalation gegeben er hat gesagt die
Russland wollte Sicherheitsgarantien die
es nicht bekommen hat und hat eben auch
davon gesprochen dass man in Kiew
wiederum offen darüber gesprochen habe
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen zu können und da
fragt ein User auf Youtube ob Putin da
Argumente schaffen will
das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen aber was
natürlich interessant ist und was aus
dieser Rede auch ganz deutlich nochmal
hervor klingt ist die Tatsache das
Putins Krieg gegen die Ukraine ein Krieg
gegen die westliche Zivilisation ist
warum bekämpft er denn die Ukraine der
Krieg hat ja angefangen mit dem Aufstand
auf dem Maidan hier hinter mir 2013 als
die ukrainische Bürgerbewegung im
Prinzip eine Orientierung nach Europa
erzwingen wollte und ein ja Russland
freundlicher Präsident das Land
verlassen hat damit hat sich ja im
Prinzip das Verhältnis zwischen Ukraine
und Russland ganz ganz deutlich auf ein
anderes Niveau begeben und seit diesem
Zeitpunkt und das ist ja auch der
Zeitpunkt wo der Krieg angefangen hat
den Russland gegen die Ukraine führt
sieht Russland dieses Land praktisch als
Stellvertreter für alles das westliche
Werte sind der eigentliche Gegner für
die Russen ist nicht die Ukraine der
eigentliche gegner ist der Westen ist
die NATO sind die Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika und das finde ich ist in
dieser Rede auch noch mal ganz ganz
deutlich durchgeklungen der Einsatz von
Atomwaffen darüber redet Russland immer
wieder und es ist ja auch so das haben
wir jetzt auch schon mehrfach im Verlauf
dieses Krieges von russischer Seite
gehört dass man die ukrainische Seite
beschuldigt hier vielleicht Chemiewaffen
einsetzen zu wollen dass die NATO hier
eingreifen könnte aber ich sage mal so
das ist alles Teil eines Narrativs in
den russland versucht sich in den Augen
der eigenen Bevölkerung eigentlich ins
Recht zu setzen das narrativ davon wir
sind hier die führende Nation die ja
den den Kampf um das eigene Überleben
den Kampf um das eigene System hier
aufnimmt und
sieht Russland hier ganz klar natürlich
das wurde ja auch gerade schon gesagt in
einer Art Opferrolle
Präsident Putin hat ja auch von
russophobie gesprochen und hat aber auch
gleichzeitig den Schulterschluss mit den
alliierten Soldaten aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg gemacht
jetzt gab es ja in der im Vorfeld gab es
irgendwie die Befürchtungen dass er die
general mobil machen ausrufen könnte
dass er einen Sieg über über den Don
Bass und das Referendum ausrufen könnte
ist man in der Ukraine jetzt schon oder
ist das das minimal dass das wenigste
was man erwarten konnte
hier im Vorfeld durchaus mehr erwartet
die Rede die wir heute gehört haben da
ist Putin deutlich unter den
eskalationsleveln geblieben mit denen
man hier gerechnet hat also hat er im
Prinzip nichts anderes getan als die
narrative von denen er ja jetzt schon
seit Wochen spricht noch einmal zu
wiederholen
zusammenzufassen in den Kontext des
heutigen Tages zu bringen und
interessant und das kann man leider auch
nicht auf Deutsch übersetzen ist
natürlich auch die Sprache und der
Sprachduktus den diese dieses Regime
mittlerweile anwendet diese wirklich
harsche Entmenschlichung die darüber
kommt auch in Formulierungen das finde
ich auch noch mal besonders beängstigend
wenn ich das höre
aber insgesamt muss man sagen ja Putin
scheint kein wirkliches Rezept zu haben
ihm fehlt die große Vision also das ist
mein Resümee aus der Rede heute
weder eine Angliederung
von Territorium noch eine Eskalation des
Krieges bis hin zu einer
general-mobil-machung also es ist
interessant das zu sehen also ich würde
das als eine Art sagen wir mal
ideologischer Kapitel Kapitulation auch
bewerten
vielen Dank Katrin für deine
eindringliche Schilderung deiner
Einschätzung und deine Analysen liebe
Grüße nach Kiew danke schön tschüss
ja und damit wollen wir uns für heute
verabschieden ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für eure Fragen und Kommentare
und auch durchaus für die kritische
Diskussion ZDF heute live sagt tschüss
bis bald